Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
I'm going to take
each of your blades,
and I'm going to
repeatedly and brutally
beat them into this antler.
I want to see what the antler's
going to do to your blades.
Devin, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do it.
I came here to test myself
with an extreme challenge,
and now it's up to the test
to see if I met and exceeded
those expectations.
Ooh!
[rock music]
Well, Devin.
We got a little issue
on the edge here.
Didn't so much chip
out and more rolled.
But it stayed straight, and
the seams that you fixed
stayed together.
So good job there.
Thank you.
Mike.
How you feeling?
- Good.
- Let's do this.
OK.
I have my concerns
about the testing.
My blade is much lighter
than the other two blades,
but bigger is not always better.
[suspenseful music]
OK, Mike.
Your knife did survive.
But we got a few issues.
You had a little bit
of a warp before.
Yep.
Now it's a good
bend in the blade.
And your blade seams
have opened up.
So, Trevor.
You look excited.
I'm really critical
of my blades.
I always see every
flaw, so I'm worried
about catastrophic failure.
[suspenseful music]
All right, Trevor.
We've got an issue.
You've got quite an
extreme roll here.
And you can see right
in the middle here
in that roll it started
to split as well.
You had an issue
before with your sanmai
not being connected all the way.
You can hear it.
That's opened up more.
And there's a spot
down here too.
Your handle is on
the large side,
but I like the way
you contoured it.
My hand just kind
of locks into place.
But the edge is
definitely an issue.
But now it's time for
the sharpness test.
Doug.
Well, bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
This is all about what
the edge of your blade
will do to these ham.
Devin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready, sir.
Let's do it.
[suspenseful music]
Nice.
All right, Devin.
The angle you have for
this lends itself to be
a very nice slicer and chopper.
You have a very
long handle here,
so I have to choke up on that.
But it does come into a
curve so I can hold on to it.
Overall, it will cut.
All right, Mike.
Time for some Canadian bacon.
You ready for this?
[laughs] I'm ready.
[suspenseful music]
All right, Mike.
Your blade does not seem
to have an edge on it.
The important thing about knives
is knives were made to cut.
Unfortunately, Mike,
your blade did not cut.
All right, Trevor, it's time.
Ready for this?
Yes, sir.
The edge damage on my blade
is pretty significant,
so I'm worried my knife
might not make the cut.
[rock music]
All right, Trevor.
Because you have a thinner blade
here, it took a lot of damage
on the strength test.
But these parts right
here are razor sharp.
That kind of geometry is able
to cut cleanly through the ham--
because your blade,
sir, will cut.
Thank you.
DOUG: Good job.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
given me their final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
Mike.
Your blade didn't make the cut.
First up, thank
you for coming down
and giving a great
effort in what is
one of our hardest challenges.
Coal forge, sanmai, in the sun.
All of the blades took
damage in the strength test.
But your blade can't
cut, and for that reason,
we have to send you home.
Please surrender your blade.
I got the boot.
I concentrated on keeping
a blunt edge so it
would survive the bone chop.
But I guess I kept it too blunt.
I'm proud of the way I performed
while I was here, so I'm
going home without any regrets.